British surgeons have developed a
groundbreaking operation to cure the
most common form of blindness
experts say the procedure could become
as routine as cataract surgery giving
hope to hundreds of thousands of people
who fear losing their sight is our
health correspondent Thomas More just
millimetres across and as thinness cling
film this is the patch of eye cells that
may well restore sight to the blind the
cells grown in the lab were transplanted
for the first time last month into an
anonymous woman with age-related macular
degeneration it'll be several weeks
before it's known how much you can see
we choose people who've had sudden
profound vision loss and they have a
chance of getting their vision back
possibly to quite a good level based on
our previous study so we're very excited
to get to that stage and find out just
sort of what it what sort of visual
recovery we're seeing scientist at
University College London took a single
stem cell from an embryo and grew it in
their lab with the right nutrients it
formed a thin sheet of special support
cells that are critical for vision and
dye in macular degeneration surgeons at
Moorfields Eye Hospital then
transplanted a patch of the cells fixing
it underneath the retina at the back of
the woman's eye it could one day be as
straightforward as cataract surgery we
can actually build banks ourselves which
means literally it would only take
anywhere from you know a matter of weeks
to put them into on the patches and put
them into the patient's around 600,000
patients in the UK have macular
degeneration
Peter seaman has lost almost all his
vision but the new cell transplant has
given him hope that he will see his
family again see their faces watch their
expressions I've got three grandchildren
live in America and a son and a
daughter-in-law there I haven't seen
them the grandchildren I'm seeing them
ever 10 patients will have the cell
transplant as part of a medical trial
the Royal National Institute of blind
people said the study was small but it
hopes stem cells will prove a
significant treatment for sight loss
Thomas More Sky News